what's up ketchup crew welcome to the
weekly ketchup on YouTube where we bring
you the biggest news of the week in
movies and TV and speaking of TV we're
breaking down what we can expect from
both beef Falcon and the Winter Soldier
series and the parasite series plus
we're looking ahead at some of the most
anticipated movies of the year that we
haven't heard much about yet so here we
go
[Music]
there are a bunch of marble TV shows
coming to Disney Plus and the first one
to arrive get excited later this year
will be the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier so let's take a look at what we
can expect from that right now on to
catch up with all the upcoming Marvel
Series in the works for the streaming
giant we made a poll in our ketchup fan
Facebook group and asked you the fans
which Marvel show are you most excited
for and swooping in first place was the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier Loki
wasn't that far behind though so thank
you guys for voting and join the group
if you haven't already so production
began late last year for the series with
an expected release date of August 2020
and it will be part of the MCU space 4
which runs through 2021 and includes six
feature films in addition to the Marvel
TV shows that we're gonna get it'll also
be running for our wallets and heads
because let's be real it's Marvel and
what a time to be alive talking in the
Winter Soldier follows
Anthony Mackie Sam Wilson and Sebastian
sands Bucky Barnes and picks up right
after Avengers end game where they were
both resurrected after being lost in
Thanos the snap heard around the world
and we'll get to see them deal with the
effects of that as well as we're turning
to their lives after five years the best
part though we'll get to know these
characters more you know on a deeper
level
as far as what else we know about the
plot footage from the Marvel Studios
Superbowl ad shows Sam tossing Captain
America's vibranium shield around so it
seems he's getting used to it or maybe
he's just really good at disco anyway it
may not be that easy for him to give up
on Falcon though so we got to stay tuned
on that and along with facing the
responsibilities of having to have
shield he may also have to face the
reality that the u.s. government has
other plans for the role and that's
because Wyatt Russell has been cast as
John Walker not the top-hat scotch guy
but a comic book villain also known as
US agent he apparently is the
government's chosen replacement for
Steve Rogers the disrespect this isn't
freedom when it comes to Bucky and
Avengers infinity war we saw him set on
the path of becoming the white wolf
which is something we could see more of
in this show and that new promo footage
also shows Bucky and a possible standoff
battle but the returning villain Baron
Zemo which is a pretty dope name I make
it to my firstborn child so Zemo played
by Daniel Bruhl also appeared in Captain
America Civil War and should play a
major role in this assuming he gets out
of prison and based on a video message
he delivered to the Marvel panel at
Comic Con fans will get to see the
characters famous purple mask from the
comics which hasn't been seen on this
MCU version of the character so you guys
just give us the show already I've
thought about nothing else all right
but if you're looking for more good guys
and gals I've got good news
also reprising her role in the MCU is
Emily VanCamp as Sharon Carter from
Captain America Winter Soldier another
character who will no doubt be dealing
with losing five years thanks to Thanos
although skipping five years in AI aging
a day seems enticing to me also
unfortunately Chris Evans has confirmed
that he won't be making a cameo as Steve
Rogers in the series but let me know
your thoughts on that in the comments I
got no plans now behind the scenes
Malcolm Spellman from Fox's Empire will
serve as showrunner and writer while
Kari Skoglund will direct all six
episodes Spellman and fumblin are both
new to the Marvel Universe macarius
directed great shows like the Americans
Vikings and The Walking Dead also
Spellman it's Bolin just
like a superteam god I love this place
Jessica we don't that really annoys cook
cause I'm banging any more enemies
action bong joon-ho and his film
parasite completely dominated the Oscars
and now the dark comedy thriller is
being adapted into an HBO series so what
could that look like let's talk about it
right now on the kitchen these certified
fresh' parasite is a hit with critics
and fans and really just anything with a
post I mean the film absolutely crushed
it this awards season according to our
awards leaderboard capping it off by
winning four Oscars including Best
Original Screenplay and Best Director
and it made history when it became the
first foreign language film to win Best
Picture
but before bones started collecting
Oscars and staring at them the way wish
someone would suit me one day bond was
already talking about expanding the
movie into a series with HBO and
producer Adam McKay the guy behind hit
shows like dead to me and succession we
aim to please as far as who we'd see
star in the show Collider is reporting
that three-time Oscar nominee and one
incredible hulk of a guy Mark Ruffalo is
at the top of their wish list to play
main characters though nothing has been
confirmed
okay so as far as what the show will be
about exactly we don't know much bong
has said in multiple interviews that he
has so many more ideas while writing the
parasite script but couldn't fit them
into the two-hour run time pensee idea
for a series and he elaborated with the
rap recently saying that his goal is to
make a miniseries that is just basically
a six hour long film and that just makes
me want to drink until next morning
thank you three income to the next
morning thank you ba has also said it is
not a remake but rather an expansion of
the universe that he created in parasite
picking up on elements that were hinted
at but not explored like what happened
between the scenes for example when the
original housekeeper comes back with
bruises on her face but we never really
find out why Bob's got a story for that
and I just blew your mind it sounded
nice where the series will be set and
whether we'll be in English or in Korean
is still open for discussion according
to the director
unfortunately production probably won't
start before next year because Mr McKay
is busy with several other projects at
the moment including directing the
Jennifer Lawrence movies bad blood and
bombs hold extra on Oscars night that
they're only in the very early stages of
development and he has said recently
that serious discussions with McKay
won't begin until March after a
much-deserved post award season vacation
you know to get over that hangover to
drink tonight but there is good news for
members of the bong hive that are
looking for TV adaptations a little
sooner because he is executive producing
a TV series that's based on his 2014
certified fresh' film Snow piercer and
it's coming to TNT
this may the show stars Jennifer
Connelly and daveed Diggs and honestly
there should be a petition for bond to
have his award she's and translator
Sharon Choi work on this because she
truly was the real MVP the series is a
prequel of sorts
inspired by the tone and world of the
original snowpiercer story but it's set
just seven years after humanity left the
planet in ruins whereas the movie takes
place fifteen years after those events
get your anxiety ready for a train that
never stops moving for your personal
safety be prepared to brace there are
quite a few movies coming out this year
that fans are eagerly awaiting but it
actually know very little about so we're
gonna hook you up and take a look at
some of the most anticipated yet
mysterious movies of 2020 right now on
the Internet once again we turn to you
and the fans in our ketchup fan Facebook
group to find out what movies you're
most excited for that we haven't really
heard much about and the overwhelming
winner in the group was Marvel's
eternals movie shocker production has
reportedly wrapped on the film according
to cast member Gemma chance Twitter
account and it has a release date set
for November 6 so like no pressure
anything that the clock is ticking the
Eternals ensemble is stacked led by
Angelina Jolie and FINA but it also
includes Kumail Nanjiani as king go
Lauren read La Paz Macari the first deaf
superhero in the MCU Brian Tyree Henry
is Fastow's Salma Hayek as a Jack Game
of Thrones alums Richard Madden as a
courage and Carrington as Dean Whitman a
human warrior who wields a mystical
sword and I'd say the man is qualified
Eternals is being directed by Chloe's
now and Marvel describes the movie as a
group of ancient aliens who have been
secretly living on earth for thousands
of years but following the events of
Avengers endgame an unexpected tragedy
forces them out of the shadows to go up
against bad guys known as deviance which
yes is an awesome name for bad guys
[Applause]
another film fans are excited for but
know nothing about is Halloween kills
the horror flick comes out October 16th
and is a sequel to 2018 certified fresh'
Halloween which was a direct sequel to
John Carpenter's 1978 original that
means Jamie Lee Curtis will once again
reprise her role of glory and the
original Michael Myers actor Nick Castle
is also returning plus fun fact
Lindsey Wallace and Tommy Doyle the two
kids Laurie was babysitting in the
original are also coming back and we got
to think Michael Myers survives because
this one sets up the eventual ending to
the story
Halloween ends which is throughout 2021
we also got to talk about the elephant
in the room or should I say the giant
lizard and gorilla that's right Godzilla
burst on is coming just in time for
Thanksgiving on November 20th and this
battle for who will be the king of the
monsters is gonna be huge
physically and literally the film is
directed by Adam Wingard and is the
sequel to both last year's Godzilla king
of the monsters and 2017 certified fresh
Kong Skull Island
and while the monsters are the true
stars they will be joined by boring old
humans like alexander skarsgård Millie
Bobby Brown Kyle Chandler and Isaac
Gonzales and by boring I mean immensely
talented
[Music]
also coming later this year but still
mystery is doomed it is the first of a
plan to part a DAP tation of the 1965
novel by Frank Herbert and will roughly
cover the first half of the book
navigating the dangerous desert planet
known as soon will be an absolutely epic
cast that includes stars like Oscar
Isaac Rebecca Ferguson Timothy shallow
Maine zendaya and Jason Momoa just to
name a few all looking for that spice
the film is due out on December 18th so
you'll have plenty of time to mentally
prepare for the giant sand worm and
finally as we were coming off the year
of the eddie murphy comeback we need to
talk about how he's coming back to
america yep coming to america but with
the number two you get it eddie will of
course be back playing multiple
characters including a cane who learns
he has a long-lost son in the united
states and must return to america to
meet the unlikely heir to the throne of
samantha other returning cast members
include Arsenio Hall James Earl Jones
and Shari Headley with newcomers like
Wesley Snipes and Leslie Jones joining
the mix and I know what you're wondering
will there be another bathtub scene
we'll have to find out on December 18
I've warned you I'll be forced to threat
alright friends thanks for tuning into
the weekly catch up on YouTube make sure
to tap that subscribe button and
notification bell so you don't miss any
future episodes of the ketchup as always
I'm Nessa Prez and we'll see you guys
next week
[Music]
[Music]